Welcome back to recitation.
In this video, I'd like us to
do the following problem, which
is going to be relating polar
and Cartesian coordinates.
So I want you to write each
of the following in Cartesian
coordinates, and that means
our (x, y) coordinates,
and then describe the curve.
So the first one is r squared
equals 4r cosine theta,
and the second one is r equals
9 tangent theta secant theta.
So again, what I'd like you
to do is convert each of these
to something in the Cartesian
coordinates, in the (x, y)
coordinates, and then I
want you to describe what
the curve actually looks like.
So I'll give you a little
while to work on it,
and then when I come back,
I'll show you how I do it.
OK, welcome back.
Well, hopefully you were
able to get pretty far
in describing these two
curves in (x, y) coordinates.
And I will show you how I
attacked these problems.
So we'll start with (a).
So for (a)-- I'm going to
rewrite the problem up here,
so we can just be focused
on what's up here.
So we had r squared
equals 4r cosine theta.
Well, we know what r squared is.
That's nice in terms
of x and y coordinates.
That's just x squared
plus y squared.
So we know that, so
we'll replace that.
And then we can actually replace
all the r's and thetas over
here pretty easily, as well.
Because we know r cosine
theta describes x.
So the Cartesian coordinate
x is the polar coordinate--
or described in polar
coordinates as r cosine theta.
So we can just write that as 4x.
And the reason I asked you to
describe the curve is because
from here, you could
say, oh, well I wrote it
in the Cartesian coordinates.
I wrote it in x, y,
and so now I'm done.
But the point is
that you can actually
work on this equation right
here and get into a form
that you can recognize.
That it'll be a
recognizable curve.
So let's see if we can sort
of play around with this,
and come up with something
that looks familiar.
And what you might think to
do, would be, say, you know,
subtract off the x squared,
or subtract off the y squared.
Try and solve for
x or solve for y.
But that can be a little bit
dangerous in this situation,
because in fact, y might
not be a function of x.
So we might run into
some trouble there.
But if you'll notice,
there's something kind of,
a glaring way we should go.
And that's because we
have this x squared
plus y squared together-- this
maybe could look something
like a circle or an ellipse
or something like that,
if we could figure out
a way to put this part
in with the x squared.
So this is kind
of-- it's a good way
to think about what direction
to head in this problem.
In particular, it would be
a bad idea for this problem
for you to subtract
x squared and take
the square root of both sides.
Because you would lose
some information about what
this curve was.
OK?
Because when you
take the square root,
you would have to
say, well, do I
want the positive
square root, or do I
want the negative square root?
We'd lose a little
bit of information.
So we do not want
to solve for y.
So let's do what I said.
Let's try and figure out a way
to get this 4x into something
to do with this x squared term.
So I'm going to subtract 4x
and rewrite the equation here.
And so you might
say, well, Christine,
this doesn't really
seem that helpful.
It's just the same
thing moved around.
But we're going to use one
of our favorite techniques
from integration, which
is completing the square.
So we can actually complete
the square on this guy right
here, and turn it
into a perfect square.
We'll have to add an
extra term, but once we
do that, we'll have a perfect
square, an extra term,
and a y squared.
And we're getting more into
the form of something that
actually looks like a circle.
So let's see.
Completing the
square on this, it's
going to be x squared
minus 4x plus 4.
How did I know that?
Well, if I want to complete
the square on this,
I need something
that, multiplied by 2,
gives me negative 4.
That's 2.
And then 2 squared is 4.
So that's where the 4 comes in.
To keep this equal, I'll add
4 to the other side, as well.
So if I add 4 to both sides, I
haven't changed the equality,
and I keep my y squared
along for the ride.
So now I have a perfect square.
What does this give me?
This gives me x minus 2
quantity squared plus 4-- plus 4
squared-- plus y squared.
So x minus 2 quantity
squared-- that came
from these three terms--
plus y squared equals four.
And now it's a curve we
can describe, clearly.
What curve is this?
Well, it's obviously a circle.
It's centered at the point 2
comma 0, and it has radius 2.
We've talked, or you've seen
this in the lecture videos,
I believe, what the
form for a circle is.
x minus a quality squared plus
y minus b quantity squared
equals r squared.
So this is, a is 2,
b is 0, and r is 2.
so it's a circle of radius
2, centered at 2 comma 0.
So we have a good way to
describe what started off
in polar coordinates.
We can now describe it
in (x, y) coordinates.
OK.
So now let's move on to (b).
And I'm going to rewrite
(b) over here as well,
so we don't have to worry
about it, looking back.
r equals 9 tan
theta secant theta.
OK.
So let's look at this.
Now, there's some
information buried in here,
in terms of (x, y) coordinates.
And one thing that
should stand out to you
is, what is secant theta?
Secant theta is 1
over cosine theta.
Right?
And if we have 1 over
cosine theta over here,
we can multiply both
sides by cosine theta,
and we get an r cosine
theta over here.
So I'm going to write that down.
That this actually
is in the same--
this is the same as r cosine
theta equals 9 tan theta.
Right?
I mean, you could get
mad at me about where
this is defined
in terms of theta,
but I'm not worrying about
that in this situation,
just right now.
We're just trying
to figure out how
we could write this in x and y.
We know what our
cosine theta is.
Again, it's x, as it was before.
What about tan theta?
Tangent theta,
remember, if you recall,
this tangent theta is
opposite over adjacent, right?
And in this case, opposite is
the y, and adjacent is the x.
This is something
you saw a picture of,
you can see a picture
of pretty easily.
So this is x is equal
to 9 times y over x.
Right?
Which is x squared is equal 9y.
So this is in fact
how you could write
this expression that's in r
and theta in terms of x and y.
And so this, if you
look at it, is actually
a parabola that goes
through the point (0, 0),
and is stretched by a
factor of 9, or 1/9.
Well, I guess you
can say, there's
a vertical stretch or
horizontal stretch,
you can pick which one it is.
And in one case, it's
going to be by 3 or 1/3.
I always mix those up.
I'd have to check.
Or by 9 or 1/9.
So essentially, it's going to be
a parabola with some stretching
on it.
Now, the problem is that
you might say, well,
it's not really all of that.
Because secant
theta is not going
to be defined for all
theta the way cosine is.
So you do potentially
run into some problems.
You might have to worry
about what part of the domain
makes sense for theta, so
that this is well-defined.
And so that this
is well-defined,
what part of the
curve is carved out.
That's a little more
technical than I
want to go in this video.
But some of you might look
at it and say, oh, she's
missing something.
Yeah, you caught something that
I'm intentionally ignoring.
So the main point
of this was just so
that you could see how you
can take these functions of r
and theta and turn them
into functions of x and y,
and then figure out kind of
what the curves might look like.
So I'm going to stop there.
Hopefully this was
a good exercise
to get you understanding how
these different coordinates
relate to one another.
And yeah, that's
where we'll leave it.